throughout my wrestling career I just I
was never home I you know I lost a
marriage with you know someone who was
very very close friend of mine we still
remain friends but just never being home
just torrent marriage apart in high
school I was an amateur Russel and that
kind of led me towards my real obsession
with bodybuilding I was constantly just
training and weight training I really
became obsessed with that and that was
all I wanted to do I thought maybe my
calling in life was to be a professional
bodybuilder or I think Arnold
Schwarzenegger was that guy he was my
action hero and he was also somebody
that I remember when I was first really
focused on bodybuilding not so much
working out with bodybuilding
I remember getting Arnold's encyclopedia
and going through that and just being
you know mesmerized by him that really
led me towards the kind of an early
obsession with bodybuilding and I found
my way into bouncing and nightclubs
really young I was I started bouncing at
nightclubs when I was 17 and uh that's
funny I was still in high school
bouncing in nightclubs and all my
friends who were too young to drink
would come in to come down to the
nightclubs that I was working in of
course I would let them in but and then
I spent you know all of my 20s just
wasted away and and you know pursuing
you know becoming huge and and bouncing
in my clubs and making easy money kind
of got wrapped up in that life that just
led to nowhere and then I kind of you
know reflected and thought you know what
could I do with myself and don't have an
education I don't really have any
training or job training but I have this
great big huge body and I thought I'll
be a professional wrestler and uh and my
first go at that was I failed miserably
yeah I don't know how much the wrestling
actually had to do with my career in
acting I think it kind of brought me out
of my shell a little bit
I did I want to eat I was funny when I
was a kid and I never hear this answer
but when I was a kid
warlord was absolutely my favorite
wrestler and it's because he was the
most immense human being I'd ever seen
in my life he was massive and I was just
I you know I was awestruck by him I was
mesmerized by him he was just so massive
later on when I was actually in
wrestling I realized that he wasn't the
most technical wrestler yeah but when I
was a kid I mean my memories are nothing
but just being awestruck you know seeing
him an excitement waiting for him to
come out for us I also think you know
being on the road with WWE is such a
grind I mean it really just developed my
work ethic and I just I think I I always
had a strong worth work ethic but
nothing like after I came out at WWII
mean they're really prepared me to just
tolerate anything now you have to have a
really thick skin there to begin with
but you also have to just pull your
weight and be you know willing to
sacrifice and I have I sacrificed a lot
I've been through a lot of injuries a
lot of you know lost time with family
throughout my wrestling career I just I
was never home I you know I lost a
marriage with you know someone who was
very very close friend of mine we still
remain friends but just never being home
just to our marriage apart but you know
going into acting was something very
different and I never ever planned on
being an action star I actually just
wanted to be an actor I actually didn't
want to be an action star I thought that
was an easy mold to fit in and now I
want to be an Access
I've taken an odd path you know my
journey but if I could go back and do it
again and I know this sounds you know
cliche but I would go back and focus on
education I always preach that preset to
my kids and I believe that because
that's something you can take with you
no matter where you are in your life or
where you are in the world you just
wherever you go you take your education
with you and it's always something you
could fall back and I think the fear of
me not having that to fall back on was
kind of the desperation that I had and
luckily I make it there's a lot of
people who don't I know some people who
haven't and that's always kind of a sad
thing but uh you know I was a fortunate
one but if I had to do it again I would
gone to school